welcome to this episode of trash taste i
am the boy the big boy
and with me i have big boy chungus and
small boy chungus
wow why am i suddenly the fattest one
here
i've been seeing either of you at the
gym lately i don't know what's been
going on with that but you know i'm very
disappointed i mean who was the one that
got a c
in cholesterol that's the [ __ ] leg
i wanted to like i wanted to open on
that because you know what
i was uh i was you know i was doing my
usual trash taste
um schedule and uh [ __ ] on the
toilet literally before recording gotta
get a get a phone call from sydney
yeah and she said oh i finally get my
health health results back in i'm like
congratulations what'd you get sydney
and she got
all a's
how is it that she gets all a's and yet
i got a c on my liver
i'm probably the one out of the four of
us who drinks the least okay
okay so so to give context this
conversation so a few weeks ago if
you're a regular trash taste viewer
you would know that we had our biannual
annual health check annual health check
and which is something that a japanese
company forces every employee to do they
have to go for a checkup
and the company also gets the results
yes yes and so we did we did our health
check up a few weeks ago i talked about
it on trash taste
and we just got our results back and
this is the first time i've ever gotten
results back
from like uh you know getting my health
check up in a foreign company uh country
sorry
and i did not know that you get graded
yeah i'm used to seeing numbers and them
saying like oh this is bad i'm like oh
well i mean it's just a funny number
isn't it yeah yeah yeah
no no you it literally i got my health
check up and i'm just like
wait they are literally grading you abc
like it's like an end-of-year school
report yeah it's i
i felt like i was doing my gcses again
or a-levels like
my god and normally i don't really care
too much
about my health checkup because i don't
know unless it's bad right you see
numbers you see
you know you see the doctor's
suggestions and they're they're just
that they're
doctor's suggestions but i don't know
why i think it's
seeing seeing my health being graded
like a school test
it just brought the asian blood out of
me right yeah yeah
yeah i was i definitely felt more
competitive yeah with my body
because i was going through my health
checkup and overall i got a b
so i was like okay i am a straight a
student
what is what the [ __ ] does this
the first thing i did when i got my
results was i phoned up my mum
and told her that and told her how well
i scored in this exam like a good asian
song
i called up the doctor and i was like
just a check this wasn't ranked was it
this was this is casual right
this is free play right please say
please say this society
please say no but yeah so i mean my
results i got like all a's which is
great as you would expect from someone
who is under the age of 30.
generally supposed to be quite healthy
right yeah yeah but i got i got a b
on bmi yeah which i mean obviously i'm
built a little different
right yeah and this is japanese bmi
which i believe is slightly different i
don't know if
i'm allowed to believe that's correct
but yeah but i mean bmi is [ __ ]
anyway
a lot of [ __ ] this is 100 muscle not fat
don't happen
and i got a c on my cholesterol right
but i got
i got like uh well i'm not sure how
cholesterol work exactly because i don't
know [ __ ] i'm dumb
but one of so there was like they had
like three different cholesterols and
all of them were like a little
you know all of them were kind of out of
touch right right
um but i was like in my head i'm like
well they gave me three c's now for my
cholesterol like but what are the odds
of one of these cholesterol being good
and the others not being good right yeah
if i go into amazing cholesterol the
other two are going to be like well [ __ ]
i mean where
i'm going to pick it up i mean i don't
know to me it was odd
i mean mine was worse because i got a c
on my liver
and i think a b on my heart rate
monitoring or something right really
and everything else was an a right what
does that mean yeah but that's the thing
right
it's like usually on your thing like i
think you two got like a doctor's like
note right or like a dog
did you guys get a doctor so you can ask
when you get the thing i don't know if
you said yes or no you can ask if you
want advice
right and i said no i don't want advice
i i said no you don't want but i
still go like i've got i don't know if
it's the same doctor's name that we're
talking about right but it was just like
a
summation of the test results should
just explain anything no it didn't
it just said um some of the values are a
bit you know
abnormal which is you know higher or
lower than we expect but
there shouldn't be anything to worry
about i didn't even get a summation did
you know
my literally like overall i got a c and
the the summation
box was just blank i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah
you're just going to tell me that my
liver is bad and that's it yeah i feel
like
should i be worried some context would
help did you have to
get did you get a note that said you had
to come in three months later as well
like i did i got that they told me back
in three months but i don't but it's
optional i mean on the thing it says
like if you get a c
they recommend you come back three
months later but i didn't get like a
note saying that i should come back
so yeah mine said you should come back
and yeah yeah yeah you have to pay for
it
and also i you know for cholesterol
he's oh i'm obviously going to turn up
and they're going to be like hey you
should uh
exercise and eat healthy i'm like thanks
dog i was going to ask because i heard i
heard you're back on the chicken and
broccoli diets no no i haven't gone
right back to the chicken breast okay i
haven't i have started
eating a little more health
consciousness is it because of the test
results i think it helped
help me be a bit more conscious it made
me you know when you would you would
maybe just go for the karate or you
would go for the chips and maybe a
little
bit like second thing like i mean i i
definitely have like
stopped drinking i think okay
i think i've only drank like once or
twice is is is the liver 100
all problems come from alcohol because i
feel like it's not just probably there's
gonna be a whole host of others
because the problem with the test
results is that they they gave they gave
you the grade
but they didn't tell you how to improve
it and i guess i guess that was our bad
because we literally
ticked the box that said we don't want
doctor's advice because i i had assumed
like any other health checkup that it
would just be like you know that you're
gonna be good right yeah it was just
like the generic
you know are you doing well do i need to
go to the hospital to really
have a lifestyle change no but as soon
as i saw the [ __ ] bee
because i got a i got a b in my blood
and i'm just like how the [ __ ] do i
improve my blood
what am i doing wrong why is my blood a
b just improve your men
just like control it like cause they
were they were like they were like going
on like
you know the the white blood or t cell i
don't
i'm not a [ __ ] i
yeah i saw the b and i'm just like as as
an asian student you know because
whenever i saw a b in a test i'm like
okay i can improve this test score
i can study a bit more i can optimize
this a bit more somehow what i found
interesting was that like i always
thought to myself that
i was very deaf for my age like because
you know i went to like a lot of
concerts growing up and just
[ __ ] basically destroyed my easter
like headphones and [ __ ] like that yeah
but so i was expecting like on the
hearing part
that i maybe get like a b or something
right i wouldn't even have complained
about it but then i saw i got an a
yeah so i was like oh it's not that i'm
deaf it's just that i don't listen
it kind of made me realize i was like oh
or my ears come back [ __ ] i know exactly
why that is and that's because i don't
know what the [ __ ] was happening when
they were talking to me oh yeah they
just put the headphones on me i'm like
wait what wait whoa whoa whoa
they were like can you then she asked me
luckily i just caught her asking can you
hear in japanese
like can you hear it and i'm like here
what what am i listening for like and
then i realized because i had done the
human benchmark test right right
recently that it was the frequency thing
yeah when you can hear it yeah but i was
like what are you what do you mean
like what am i hearing for like a bulb
like what i didn't know what was
happening but i was like oh okay [ __ ]
all right
how did you because with the eyesight
thing right you have to do like the it's
like a circle yeah yeah it's cut out
right
yeah yeah how did you guys say that in
english oh no i said it in japanese
oh yeah because i i really [ __ ] up in
the eyesight thing because i didn't know
what they were like looking for right so
i thought it was like a normal eyesight
test thing where now when i was just
like uh
e yeah because because okay so
to explain the eyesight thing they have
this circle and have like one of like
either up down
left or right that's cartel and right
now the diagonals as well it cut out
i didn't see diagonals i didn't see
diagonals yeah there were diagonals no
no no no i only saw up down left right
they were diagonal no because i caught
all of them right
yeah i did too but they were diagonal
there was no diagonal there was no doubt
they gave me they usually have diagonals
right
i've never seen diagonals because the
only reason i knew about this test is
because when i
exchanged my driving license from
british to japanese i had to do the
exact same thing right yeah and i was
just
it was this exact same thing again yeah
and there was no diagonals i mean i
definitely got it right because i came
back with like a one point two she could
be like
just men talking about diagonal life
yeah
yeah because right next to the circle
thing you had like the letters as well
so i was just reading out letters when
they were asking what direction
i would have said what direction is
missing
because i was wondering why she was
looking at me really weird
and i'm just like and she kept asking me
can you see can you see and i'm just
like
yeah yeah yeah let me just read out the
letters for you so why are they all
roast
this is easy as [ __ ] yeah luckily i've
done the simulation before so that's
yeah i was right not panicking as much
but
yeah man i mean i i click no to the
health advice because i just figured
that it was going to be the same old
you know yeah just eat healthy listen
yeah because let's be honest right if
it's if it's
unless it's something you know bad like
really bad that actually requires
treatment
right they're just going to tell me hey
you should exercise more and eat healthy
yeah you know i do most of that anyway
yeah
because you know i mean like i think for
cholesterol it's pretty simple it's
pretty simple literally just
yeah but for some of them like for
example liver or blood
you look at that results in little yikes
yeah it's like it's like a number of
factors it's like what do you even start
with how do i improve my white blood
cell count i don't know do i just take
an injection
of why blood cells what do what do you
want me to do i have a theory right
this is this could be a very uh pleasant
theory i don't know
my theory was because we got this health
checkup done right after like christmas
and my theory was well i've just been
drinking and eating straight for like
three weeks
this is clearly come on we got to write
this off this isn't yeah of course my
collateral is going to be higher i had
like 8 000 calories three days ago
of course it's gonna be higher sure
maybe i don't know but i didn't drink a
lot in christmas
yeah so much yeah yeah i think i
definitely skewed the results that's
that's what i'm gonna
chalk it down to i mean
please validate me in the comments i
don't want i don't want to hear if you
have an alternative theory just say if
i'm right
yeah i just found i just found it funny
how like i think it's
i think it's this is different
definitely the difference between like
asian culture and
like western culture where i feel like
in asia living in asia they try to
make everything a test and everything
kind of competitive and that's just
i that's how i was raised as well so
whenever i see a grade
i like something in my blood drives me
to try and improve that grade
yeah that's true yeah and i don't know
if i'm just like over competitive or
i just maybe well i think it's good
right because if you're the kind of
person who you are
yeah those things work really well but
there's obviously some personalities out
there that
when they hear oh by the way like your
bmi is bad or your liver's bad where
they're just like instead of like
wanting to be like well [ __ ] you i'm
going to improve it it's like
oh [ __ ] i guess it's just like there's
no hope like why why is it like
working and then it should make it worse
right yeah but i don't know i feel like
as as you know as someone who grew up in
you know kind of kind of both cultures
i think a lot of toxicity can come in
putting so much
value into a grade or a test and i feel
like definitely living in asia
they put way too much value into test
results and school results
do you think there are like some schools
and like companies where like they get
bullied if you got like a bad rating
i think it's totally i it's definitely a
thing in asia because i heard
because [ __ ] got a d in his blog
yeah because because in in in asia i i i
don't know if i'm talking about my ass
but
you see in like anime definitely where
you get the test results right
and it's like publicly posted yeah so
you you publicly know what your
fellow classmates got yes and that to me
seems like a lot of pressure they do
that for like university like entrance
exams as well they're like
they're like yeah create a huge
billboard in front of the school and it
has like your number on it and if your
number doesn't show up you basically
fail yeah brother
so it's like a public execution they
literally make a public tournament arc
for your test results
like no one no wonder they put so much
value on testing
and i think that can that can definitely
that
to me from my experience can definitely
skew with your mentality when you
go out of schooling and you realize that
not everything in
life is graded and not everything in
life has a percentage or a grade that
uh judges your results and how well you
do yeah i think especially because of
the given the industry that we've gone
into
which is entertainment if you will uh
that have you called trash taste
entertainment but
we're trying our best here um i feel
like the skill set
is nearly 180 it compares of what what
you learn in school
right it's purely based on like i feel
like social skills and 90 percent of our
job
oh yeah right being able to read a room
being yeah like talk but you know
i mean obviously there is a lot of
technical aspect obviously like learning
how to set up all this equipment
but the majority of it can't be taught
in a classroom oh no and it's kind of
and you can i mean
you know how can you grade someone's
social skills imagine we started doing
that ooh
i mean could you imagine oh connor
you know you were on s but ever since
the event happened you've been kind of a
bomber you're kind of a d now
you know what i mean like yeah it's like
it's like getting graded for every tweet
you make right yeah
honestly if you're like how's the b plus
tweet yeah yeah yeah that's true
yeah he's gonna fight away